for today's classic interview it's a
true classic it's one of our favorites
my interview with Pastor James David
Manning from February 5th of 2015 this
is that eccentric preacher dude who
believed that Starbucks was using semen
from gay men to quote flavor up their
lattes I don't think that much
introduction is necessary for this it is
a real classic and I'm glad to bring
this to many of the new people in our
audience who may not have seen or heard
this one at first aired back in 2005
with no further delay my interview with
Pastor James David Manning I'm joined
today by Pastor James David Manning who
is the chief pastor at ATLA World
Missionary Church in Harlem here in New
York City just a few miles north of our
studio pastor Manning has been a strong
critic I think is even an understatement
to say of President Obama comparing
President Obama to Satan Hitler calling
him a long-legged mack daddy pastor
Manning is your objection to president
obama primarily to him as a person or to
his political views him as a person but
surely because of his personhood his
political views are demented of evil as
well but that stems from him as a person
so we'll let it rest there are you a
political conservative in other words do
you when you say you disagree with
President Obama on his views is that
because you're you're a conservative no
I'm a Christian I I wholeheartedly
support the Word of God the Bible and so
I wouldn't necessarily call myself a
conservative in that regard a Christian
point of view covers both the political
and also the theological perspective
when you refer to President Obama as a
long-legged mack daddy this is something
which has been turned into sort of a
joke amongst many but I've never
actually heard you explain what what
that means what what exactly did you
mean by that
it is both a spiritual and a social
designation that is spot-on for who he
is as a person personality
term long-legged mack daddy derives from
the street hood term of being a daddy
young boys a few years ago in their
sexual encounter with young girls within
the hood and the moment of the sexual
experience will ask the young lady who's
your daddy in and out of did that
question was raised and it may demand
some macho and the woman very submissive
though the term Mack has a term that has
supplanted the term the old term the
iceberg slim term of a pimp which has a
very negative connotation to it the it
so it's been supplanted by the word mack
so when men who earn their living from
putting women out on the street or
otherwise taking money from women for
sexual favors with in concerted mack
well a mack daddy is a person who
professionally does that does nothing
else but that would women and a
long-legged mack daddy is the most
successful pimp on planet earth and
women which women has President Obama
put out on the street well you know the
the ones that voted for him the one that
gave loads and loads of money and told
tons and tons of lies and ran extreme
interference on behalf of him and all
those old white women sitting up in the
stadiums a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand strong during the 2008 campaign
watching him speak and swooning over him
nothing more than the biggest pimp job
I've ever seen but can you name any of
the ones that are now out on the street
as you say well you know the pimp game
as the term pimp has been usurped by the
term mack the pimp game doesn't run the
streets anymore it's a very
sophisticated organ kind of an
organization now where you call girls
you simply call up or you can go to the
Gramercy lifts or somebody's this and or
you can go
online it's still pimping I said oh all
Obama did it where it's like a high
class of pimping of sorts he's very
little I see hot SEC pimpin uh call it
that okay you talked about this
Christian worldview that you have and
for people who don't know your
background you did you've admitted to
breaking into as many as a hundred
houses you have threatened people with
guns you spent about three and a half
years in prison and in prison is where
you develop you became a Christian so to
speak what happened in prison that
brought you to Jesus first of all I
didn't threaten people with guns I put a
double-barrel shotgun sawed-off shotgun
in the mouth of a low-life small-time if
you will mafioso type deafening gasp
azusa I put it in his mouth and
threatened to blow his brains that's the
only person on this planet I've ever
threatened with the gun so we need to be
straight about that first I don't know I
don't know if I broke into a hundred
houses I know over a period of about
three or four years I went into a large
number of them and stole things that I
had no business stealing and I regret to
this very day that I lived that life
there's not a day that goes by that I do
not regret that however one of the
things that happened to me while in
prison I turned around and looked at
myself and said what on earth am I doing
here how did I get here why did I turn
out to be the kind of person that I
turned out to be that would end up in
prison this is not my father's son
so I got down on my knees and I simply
wanted to be and I didn't fully
understand but I wanted the bird of how
I treated my family how it embarrassed
my school teachers and my parents I
wanted that burden lifted from me and
not the only person I knew could do it
was Jesus he not only lifted that burden
for me but it saved me and it's changed
my life dramatically and how did you
know to go to Jesus and let me kind of
contextualize that question you go into
prison and you recognize that you're
you're on the wrong path like you said
you're not your father's son did you
test out like did you check with Allah
did you get it with you know the God of
Abraham and then Jesus and then the for
the god of the Flying Spaghetti Monster
how
did you ultimately settle on Jesus I'm
glad you raised that question because in
prisons and during the 70s when I was
there the Islamic law influence is still
very powerful most men convert to Islam
because it gives them a sense of being
protection etc and so I did I did bow
down to Allah twice in my cell on two
consecutive nights thinking that that
would be bring what I needed nothing
happened when I prayed to Allah but the
very first night I prayed to Jesus who
was my grandmother's God and the god of
my father and my uncles and odds for
many many moons when I prayed to him
instantly
the power of God met me and I was
changed there's no doubt about it
otherwise I wouldn't be talking to you
today had I not been dramatically
changed by the power of the blood of the
Lord Jesus Christ and it's interesting
because in your political views you've
been very strongly condemning
homosexuality for for many years you've
talked about gay people being stoned to
death you've talked about sodomite
Slayers you've talked about gay seamen
and Starbucks coffee but I want to put
that conversation off a little bit are
you what's your reaction to the reality
that you want to see gays stoned to
death and Isis wants to stone gays or
they've even thrown gays off of the
roofs of buildings are you comfortable
sharing a view so precisely with an
extremist Muslim group well I got to
tell you that if my view does not come
from Isis or any other jihadist for that
matter no no I know let me let me
clarify the question I didn't suggest
your views came from that but what I'm
saying is they happen to be identical
well yeah that's why I'm trying to say
to you I'm trying to tell you that my
views come from the Word of God from the
Book of Leviticus from the writings and
teachings of Moses that says that every
sodomite needs to be stoned to death not
just sodomized but adulterers as well
that's where my point of view comes from
so now if it happens to be synonymous
with
cases or some other point of view that's
not my problem my problem is to
reverence the Word of God to trust it to
preach it to teach it as the word says
stone and that's what it says that is no
but but so but so you admit that the the
Christian doctrine you claim your views
are informed by has led you to the exact
same place that the the followers of
Isis have been led to by supposedly
following Muslim doctrine you recognize
that wholeheartedly
no I think what you're what you're
failing to understand is you're trying
to make what the Muslims do worse than
what Moses has said do in fact any
Christian any true Christian a follower
of the Word of God were probably more
extreme than Isis or in some of the
other jihadist when you look at the
teachings of the Lord Jesus Christ and
the things that he has said in the NS
sanction because Jesus said that
whatever laws that Moses have put
forward including stoning that he
supports it wholeheartedly and all of
heaven and earth would pass away before
he would ever change one jot or one
tittle of what Moses has said so I think
what many are trying to do is to say
that Isis is somehow another worse in
Christianity no it isn't no it isn't no
it is that the Word of God is the word
of God let me remind the audience were
speaking with Pastor James David Manning
we're going to take a break on our TV
and radio program and we'll continue
speaking with pastor Manning including
his claims about sodomite semen in
Starbucks coffee the full interview will
be available on our youtube channel so
let's go to that next pastor Manning
you've talked about that Starbucks uses
gay semen in their coffee to make it
taste good
where did that come from well I think
you know that there was an article that
was first promoted suggesting this idea
and was then later retracted as just a
hoax let me say something to you about
marketing and about major corporations
no but let me pause it because we have
limited time with you and we talked a
lot about marketing and corporation
I just want to know why you think that
would be specifically don't is Hebrew
happy because it's true because gays
tend to love other each other's semen
and it flavors up the coffee they like
the taste of it there's no doubt about
that how do I know that it flavors the
coffee well because that's what it does
like the cocaine that was put in
coca-cola going back a century ago that
flavored up coca-cola and they now
introduced have introduced a synthetic
cocaine that gives coca-cola the same
kind of flavor and excitement and
addiction of taste what Starbucks has
done the exact same thing that coca-cola
has done except they've done it with
semen but enlighten me under logistics
so if I go into a Starbucks and I say I
want a you know medium vanilla latte bs
whatever thing I want right and I see
them take the different ingredients the
milk and then the coffee and whatever at
what point are they collecting the semen
where when are they inserting it in my
drink oh it's already in the process
it's already in the pipeline and by the
way
Starbucks is already have just
introduced a flat white a drink light a
Ormoc I'm not sure which it is that's a
cover for semen right it is eerily it is
if they're almost mocking me like
they're saying la hahahaha will show you
that we're doing it and the stupid
Starbuck audience a patronage doesn't
have enough sense to believe you Manning
will actually put it real hide it in
plain sight I mean this is absolutely
incredible what Starbucks is do it
because they recognize the audience and
their patron is just a bunch of idiots
who will drink it no matter what's in it
they drinking it was cyanide in it well
listen the the gay semen in coffee aside
I think that there's no question that
that the issue of homosexuality is a
really important one to you and I think
that you you admitted in an interview
with Jenkin Anna over the Young Turks
that at one point you yourself were
tempted by what you call the gay
lifestyle what would tell us about that
I don't know about the gay lifestyle
that's an addition
I was in prison in my early twenties and
yes I was tempted to engage in a sexual
intercourse with a sodomite no doubt
about you I did I didn't do it and thank
God the gingka nanner had the integrity
to publish the fact that I said I was
tempted but I didn't yield to temptation
listen I thought about at one point in
time while I was in prison committing
suicide I didn't do that either
but I was tempted but what so what were
your temptations brought on by in other
words you were you're in prison you
considered yourself I assume a
heterosexual male and what happened that
made you say maybe I'll have the gay gay
intercourse been a long time without a
woman that's what it was it was a long
time without a woman and you know just
watching it go on and and seeing other
people do it and I thought to myself
well you know maybe I will
yeah you know I didn't but I thought
about it but it had been a long stretch
without a woman but in the situation you
were in it struck you as an idea that
might have been pleasurable yeah I did
know I thought it would you do I don't
know if it's something that I would be
proud of in that regard pleasurable but
in terms of sensations of the flesh no
doubt about it that was the only reason
I would consider sensation of the flesh
but I would not have been proud of what
I can tell you that you know pastor
Manning I've spoken over the years to
many individuals who condemn
homosexuality to varying degrees you
know similar to the way you do including
for example dr. Paul Cameron and many of
them have admitted to having had I guess
what we could call colloquially gay
temptations right what do you think of
the fact that there are so many
outspoken anti-gay activists who end up
being gay Steve wiles George recurs and
Ted Haggard and pastor Eddie long I
don't know if that's someone that you
saw in the kind of pastoring world
Troy king and Glen Murphy jr. why do you
think that there's this path that is
existed in several dozen of these
individuals who are publicly very
anti-gay activists and then it turns out
they themselves are gay well you know
not every person whose aunt I gay has
been gay or is gay them cell of course I
think we
you'd understand be clear about that but
the other thing I think this old adage
in the preaching industry if you will
that one of the hardest preachers is
someone who was either former drug
addict or former criminal or one who
really was at the pit of hell living an
awful life that person usually preaches
the hardest against the things that they
themselves used to be hit you're looking
at one I mean I lived a pretty wretched
life for a brief period of time and I
suppose that the reason why I preached
so hard is to warn people don't go down
the road of hurt and destruction that I
went down don't go down that road but
it's got the opposite pass though
because with these individuals they were
first doing the anti-gay preaching and
then they stopped and it turned out that
they were gay any long and Ted Haggard's
were nothing but outright hypocrites and
and that needs to be clear they were
flat-out hypocrites because while thus
while they were preaching against it
they were doing the very thing that they
say was wrong what a hypocrite but then
you got a lot of pastors like that yes
there are lots of pastors who are
hypocrites a last thing I want to touch
on you've said that both george w bush
and his father had anal sex with a
hundred men how do you know that because
they are part of the well-known
fraternal group out of Yale University
known as Skull and Bones and it's public
knowledge that the Skull and Bones
organization in order to be initiated
first of all you had to lie in a casket
and let men
urinate on you and then a part of the
process you understand it as circular if
you will masturbation squad to be a part
of Skull and Bones and then you also had
to be penetrated by the elder persons in
skull and bone everybody knows this is
public knowledge and George Bush Senior
and George Bush jr. are bonafide members
of Skull and Bones that means they have
been penetrated by at least 100 men and
their anus area and how do you know that
it's a hundred might it have been 95
well it could have been could have been
less but generally that's the number
that kind of gets the attention of
everybody and if it could have been
fewer it could have been none also right
no it could not have been none
could not have been none No and because
skullenbones will not accept you without
that practice it's hideous but that's
what they do that's what these
fraternities do some do even worse than
that but yes George Bush has been
penetrated by other men and has also
been doused in semen of other men while
he lie in a casket other men have
masturbated in his face sounds like
quite an evening hey just out of
curiosity how many people go to your
church for a typical sermon I'm sorry to
hear would you say how many people
attend a typical sermon at your church
why do you want to know that I'm just
curious what the scene is like up there
what the semen is like no no no I mean
what the scene is like what's it like -
it's extraordinary not invite you to
come one of the more extraordinary
experiences that anybody can ever have
at anytime it's a wonderful experience
you know most people who come to our
church find it the most unusual
welcoming warm place where people a
genuine the Spirit of God is present the
power of God most people declare they've
never experienced anything like what
they experienced in our church and I
invite you to come no I have no question
that it would be a unique and singular
experience but I'm just trying to find
out would it be a congregation of ten or
a hundred or a thousand what would I
expect oh it could be a congregation of
20,000 depending on the time in which we
are preaching so you're saying sometimes
you get 20,000 people at your church in
Harlem if sometimes it could be more
than that incredible incredible and that
that certainly is seems to be a story
that has been missed by the corporate
media let me remind the audience we've
been speaking with Pastor James David
Manning chief pastor of the Atlit world
Missionary Church just a few miles from
us in Harlem it's truly been an
incredible experience pastor I
appreciate you joining us today oh thank
you for having me ring again if you will
I'll keep the light on for you thank you